welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about your friends
your family and those closest to you the
ones you share your dreams with your
fears with and your biggest secrets with
the people that you can trust with
anything and how all of those people are
all alien shape-shifters right here to
infiltrate our society and bring us down
from the inside did i say big question i
meant infowars oh my gosh yeah this is
gonna this is gonna give some people
some complexes look out you're safe
you're safe wherever you are
except for you
jerry you're not safe jerry you're in
trouble all jerry's um all of your
friends and loved ones are aliens
they're alien shape-shifters my name is
mt and i'm here today with off-screen
producer brandon who may or may not be a
scroller
i mean
i don't know i think i remember being me
but maybe those are false memories
implanted in me uh by some sort of
supreme intelligence or something i i
don't know what's going on i don't know
who i could trust am i me am i me
[Laughter]
or maybe i'm just saying that to keep my
cover intact oh no you're the scroll i
knew it all right brady what's our big
question for today well mt with the
secret invasion series coming to disney
plus very soon it's got all of us
wondering who out there could be a
scroll this is gonna be the big the big
question the big debate as we get closer
and closer to secret invasion uh we get
this question all the time here at the
channel and everyone's got their own
opinions but now i think it's the
perfect time to really dig into it it
all leads us to this week's big question
who in the mcu is already a scroll let's
talk about new scrolls who's the scroll
who's the scroll in hiding who's been
hanging out there just scrolling along
scrolling and listening to skrillex
scrolling and skrillexin 24 7. that's
what the squirrels love to do i bet the
squirrels took over squirrelex and now
it's rolex yeah i don't know what
skrillex is supposed to look like he
could be a skrull exactly anybody could
be a skull really and there are a lot of
big names and new faces that will be
coming to the mcu in the secret invasion
series and undoubtedly some of those
people will be scrolls i hate to break
it to you but like it's it's probably
gonna happen it's gonna break all of our
hearts a lot of these new people will
definitely be scrolls it's it's true oh
yeah we can't trust all these newbies
like no
no what the heck's a i mean look i love
you k bishop but like you know
a little bit too good to be true a
little bit too good to be true i gotta
keep my eyes on you i don't know oh i
think you're gonna keep your eyes on her
just fine
you don't need some grand scroll that
wasn't a problem i was already keeping
watch you're already doing your due
diligence but it's also very likely that
this series will reveal that one or more
of some of our beloved current mcu
members were replaced by a scroll at
some point in mcu history so let us
break down some of our top candidates
for secret scrolls let's get into it
brandon but let's start off with our you
know the the star of the show the star
of secret invasion because we got to
consider it a theory because we know
he's in secret invasion and that the
show will be dealing some time during
the blip and some evidence on fury um
it's already confirmed that he has a
scroll counterpart in taylor so like you
know he sort of has already been
replaced by a skrull right um and he has
been confirmed to have been blipped and
he's also a very powerful individual in
human society right and he's a prime
target for impersonating because that's
what the squirrels do they just they
don't just impersonate your neighbor for
fun it's like hey i'm just going to take
over your neighbor let's do that no
they're taking over the big names in
society like the president the senators
all those people so they can take over
slowly so yeah that's that's fury that's
a good yeah he's a good candidate like
like you said we know he's been a skrull
has taken his place at some point
there's lots of people
you know with the news that the show is
going to cover sometime during the blip
and you know nick fury's supposed to be
gone during that you know was it nick
fury that was blipped was it talos that
was blipped and we thought it was nick
fury you know like all this confusing
stuff but that would mean talus would
have had to have had the captain marvel
pager because we saw him run out so i i
don't know yeah uh and now that there
could be like a fun misdirection on this
show where we were like oh we know talos
can be nick fury but what if it's
another skrull being nick fury not talos
that could be that could be intense that
could be intense this is true like you
have multiple nick furys it's true like
multiple skrulls could uh take the same
human yeah because like no one called
dibs
but there's also you know nick fury's
best friend maria hill maria hill has a
confirmed scroll counterpart in soren
because we saw that in spider-man far
from home her and taylor's are working
together on behalf of nick's fury on
earth while uh nick fury and maria hill
are off doing god knows what in space um
even though we don't it's not confirmed
that maria is in space but i think we
get a problem she usually goes where
nick fury goes she she hangs around him
she runs
her right hand gal but also um
she's a prime squirrel target due to her
close proximity to highly classified
people and information like she probably
knows a lot of things herself and she
probably has access to a lot of stuff
even though um shield has been disbanded
for a little bit but like she like she's
probably if nick fury is not available
maria hill is the person that you want
to impersonate the next best thing she
gets a lot done you know she's able to
do a lot now here's something crazy
maria hill
could have always been a straw she could
have been a skull from like day one like
there is no real maria hill right like
the maria hill we see get dusted in in
uh infinity war that could be soaring
like soren could have just slid in as
maria hill like very early on because
you know nick meet nick fury meets the
skrulls in captain marvel in the 90s
right and from then on he could start
putting them in places and maybe
like you know uh there was just a lady
walking down the street and soren copied
that lady and then was like okay now i'm
gonna we're gonna you know and then nick
fury makes all this fake paperwork for a
maria hill and he's like this is my
right-hand person maria hill but the
whole time from uh iron man all the way
through in game it's actually soaring
the whole time that's maria hill the
whole time i think that would be like a
good reveal and i put a lot of i don't
think there's a real maria hill i think
it's always been
a scrum
i would love that so much it's like hey
maria hill's always been a squirrel like
there's never been a maria hill we just
made it up because like we just needed a
cover i would really dig that i think
that like because we don't know a lot
about maria in the mcu yeah she's always
been like she's probably like one of the
most mysterious mcu characters that we
have um
we could totally do that i feel like
marvel studios could totally be like
yeah she was a squirrel this entire time
that's why we didn't really show her
show you guys her life because her life
has been very weird and very space-like
very space-like yeah i love that idea
that's a really good idea well those are
the easy ones like those two are like of
course there's girls we already seen
this we've seen them so let's really
start getting into it because like our
next sprawl suspect is of course sharon
carter recently revealed to be the power
broker in falcon and the winter soldier
uh because we see the sudden shift into
the role of the power broker and that's
like a little bit too suspicious
all right like you were like really cool
with steve at in winter soldier like i
mean in civil war you guys did a little
kiss and then like now you're just evil
like what's what's going on with that
yeah because seems kind of weird very
suspicious and like the way she's able
to infiltrate madrapore and stuff so
quickly like that would make sense if
she's a skrull and is able to like
become whoever she wants to get the
power she needs
and then it's just like the power broker
and that's also how no one maybe knew
who the power broker was because every
time she met someone she could have just
taken a different form right
exactly now i assume that sharon carter
that was getting fresh with steve rogers
you know back in the day i think that
was a real person i don't think sharon
carter's been one the whole time right
because i think i think nick fury was
smart enough to know that he knows
scrolls exists and as he's leading
shield he probably had something where
he was like we got to x-ray everybody
all the time because we know the
internal organs don't match a human
right the mimicry is mainly on the
outside so i'm pretty sure nick fury
would be smart enough to be like we need
to check agents all the time just to
make sure that they're people and not
skrulls not robots not enough anything
else so i think sharon carter was real
wasn't a scroll and then at some point
during this blip
that's when she could have been swapped
out who knows where the real sharon
carter is but i like the idea that
sharon carter is a scroll that makes a
lot of sense i think there's a lot of
opportunity between the last time we see
her in civil war and um when we see her
and falcon winner soldier for her to be
replaced by a scroll yeah saying i think
that she's in a really good position to
be a scroll because like she's a person
with a lot of contacts that used to be
in shield person that like knows how to
move around and like a person that
people trust because uh she's the niece
of peggy carter right who's like a hero
in human history so it's just like yeah
like that's a really good role to have
especially
um if you're a skrull and you're sharon
carter who has all these connections and
is now evil as a power broker and uh
yeah in like if i'm a skrull army trying
to gain influence like of course i'm
gonna want all the the black market
weapons and and everything that like the
earth has um in my arsenal as much as
possible for when i need to start
shooting in a real war okay here's one i
got one for you mt all right and this is
a suspect that might break our hearts if
they're revealed to be a scroll and that
is one mr harold happy hogan okay oh no
this could be really heavy to take
though if happy is a scroll he's
certainly proven himself to be a very
good one you know what i mean he's
helped peter yes he helped pepper and
morgan all of those after tony's death
he was there like helping out being
there but could he be a skrull okay he's
he's someone who is very close to tony
stark which makes him a great candidate
you know you want to keep eyes on tony
stark and everything he's doing and he
makes sense because he could have been
put into place by nick fury like very
early on you know we talk about like
nick fury
you know meeting the girls in the 90s he
knows how important howard stark was is
uh and he knows that his son is going to
take over and maybe he's like oh i gotta
get someone close to the sun i'm gonna
invent this happy hogan person uh and
put this scroll in there okay also
there's a lot of evidence because in if
you if you know the secret invasion
series from the comics
jarvis the long-time companion of tony
stark turned out to be a scroll we don't
have a live-action jarvis in the mcu but
happy hogan in the mcu is kind of a
mixture of happy hogan from the comics
and a little bit of jarvis mixed in
there
so that's why i think you know there's a
very there's a very good chance uh that
happy hogan could be a skrull there's
also there's this big theory out there
of a little clue a little hint to rooney
that may have been planted if you
remember in spider-man far from home
okay happy comes to help peter and
peter's like i [ __ ] up i messed
everything up i screwed up and they make
a new suit
and then happy like face time he calls
nick fury as the battle on the uh the
london bridge is starting the tower
bridge excuse me excuse me brits the
tower bridge is starting to pop off
right
he calls nick fury and he's facetiming
and he's like over at mr starks going
through his belongings apparently it was
a surfboard that you left behind people
over there said they think that nick
fury was a surfer a guy said appearance
is going to be deceiving not mine and
you know nick fury's like
don't talk to me and he hangs up
and the whole point of that call was
like the appearances can be deceiving
thing to let nick fury know that becker
isn't good blah blah blah blah that nick
fury is a skrull okay and happy hogan
specifically says
i found this surf board if you recall
the events of captain marvel when the
scrollians first land in the water and
they're coming out of the water and the
first thing they see to copy is a person
carrying a surfboard empty and this
could have been a clue because there's
like four there's four scrolls that come
out of the water there's talos sauron
and a couple other scrolls one of those
girls dies and they cut them open that
other one we don't ever really know what
happens to that one we kind of lose
track of that one okay
that could have become happy and happy
is telling happy the scroll is telling
nick fury aka talos to scroll surfboard
surfboard surfboard that's like the code
word right because that's the first
thing they saw when they got to earth
and they both that's true they both
became the woman and talos was like i
get to be the surfer chick and he's like
so
happy hogan could be a scroll and the
clothes the clues have been there since
far from home i have never ever put that
surfboard connection together that is
such a good idea it's weird it's a
little weird now i know now i don't
trust him
but we should trust him he's a good guy
he's a he's a great guy he's been
keeping tony alive he's been keeping
pepper alive peter alive morgan a lot
like he's a good guy if he's a skrull
he's a good guy he's not doing anything
nefarious i mean if he is if he's been
waiting right till this moment to spring
his trap he's too late
you should have sprung your trap a long
time ago my guy seriously i mean he got
distracted with a dating aunt may yeah
he's like oh wait i forgot to be evil
i'm uh yeah
i mean i'm uh
if i'm an alien sent to earth to
infiltrate
and take over and then i meet on may
forget forget my previous plan yeah i
got a new plan i dropped all of my plans
i'm here to conquer uh may you know what
i'm talking about
[Laughter]
but no i i really like now that is my
head canon now like that surfboard
connection it's just very specific
very specific very small
yeah y'all are hella specific we've got
to talk about pepper pots because like i
feel like it's fair to consider her as
well because tony helped cure pepper
after she was injected with extremists
so he might have noticed at that point
that her internal physiology was not
human so like you know so like she might
not be a scroll because like tony is
very familiar with with her body
internal organs at this point that
sounds weird oh my god i don't feel like
that oh but also the fact that
but also the fact that they had a kid
means that she was a human up through
endgame so like what about now like what
about after endgame because with tony
gone it could make pepper a prime target
as she is in charge of stark industries
at this point as far as we know like um
it seems that like stark industries is
still a big player in the mcu universe
and having
pepper be a scroll or be replaced by a
scroll after the events of end game
would be really appropriate i think that
having pepper be a scroll before end
game would be a big time really
really weird
because like you know she's the one that
says goodbye to tony and like in the
while he dies and like it just yeah it
would be really weird it's like oh it
was secretly me i was kissing
what's kissing some random chick's
husband
[Laughter]
uh but yeah no um i think that yeah
after ed game like it makes sense for
pepperdine if a skrull slips in after
end game and then because now that the
government just like confiscated all the
stark tech right after far from home if
if a skrull had gotten in charge of
stark and there's a scroll in the
government somewhere and that's girl's
like yes take all of our stuff she
doesn't put like why didn't pepper put
up a fight to keep the government from
taking all the stark tech right maybe
because this pepper's a scroll and she
let it happen because she's got a skrull
on the inside i don't know i don't know
i don't know mt i don't know i don't
know it sucks you you can't you can't
trust anyone
these marvel streets man no you can't
trust him the secret of asian season man
yeah well i have to consider every
single person yeah if we if we're in the
sphere of tony stark right now we gotta
also consider
james rhodes aka roadie a.k.a war
machine rodeo rodeo baby we know
roadie's already already had one
significant physical change from iron
man 1 to iron man 2 yes big change
yeah could have could have snuck a shake
could have snuck a scroll in there who
maybe didn't get the copyright i don't
know he's like close enough
close enough
uh
rhodes wasn't a scroll at least all the
way through civil war because that's
when he gets shot by vision he drops
he's paralyzed from the waist down or or
has significant spinal damage i don't
know how long it goes on right i don't
know if he's been cured yet but at some
point he's going to get x-rayed after
that happens and they would have noticed
but maybe sometime after there a new a
new one slips in right a skrull slips in
as rhodes gets control of like the war
machine armor now we saw like a little
preview that's kind of uh snuck out from
comic-con there's a scene where like uh
uh in secret invasion that was in the
the trailer they showed at comic-con
where nick fury is talking to rhodes and
says do you know the something like do
you know all the people on your security
detail almost like warning roads like
someone on your detail might be a skrull
but what if
rhodey is a scroll you know what i mean
he's already a scroll uh he's a great
candidate he would have he's a
high-ranking military officer right uh
he has access to the war machine armor
if a scroll wants to get in there
boom because the skrulls can't copy
powers right so they're usually they
usually try and be normal people they
can copy the look of powers like they
can copy wings and claws and stuff they
can't copy power powers unless you get
yourself a super scroll then you then
you can copy the powers no i think that
roadie is a like a prime target another
prime target here because like he is
one of the like he's the only person
that has inherited an iron man suit he's
the only person that has the right at
this point to don an iron man suit and
that's what people seem to want like we
know that armor wars
i mean may or may not be coming it's
coming baby it's coming
uh hopefully fingers crossed
um but like and wait we didn't see it on
their face five yeah
we got d23 baby but like maybe this is
the case because like they decided to
make rhodius like you know what we're
not gonna do armor awards with roadie we
might do armor wars with riri but we're
not going to do it with roadie because
rhodey is now a skrull in the mcu we
have a different plan for that so no i i
think it'd be really fun uh for perotti
to be revealed as a scroll it would
really break my heart because uh you
know you know i love being a good black
superhero uh that's unscrawled but like
you know it would be really interesting
to see what the fcu did when they
squalified rhodey because um that's it
that's a big get for the scroll empire
big gap if they they got rhody let's
talk about um io um from uh wakanda
because uh she's one of the key members
of the dora milaje here and she's a
great candidate to be a scroll
considering that she has an inside eye
watching all of wakanda and their
technology like she is one of the most
one of the most trusted people in
wakanda and uh she's very close with the
uh wakandan royal family so like it
would just make sense for her to
to sort of for the scroll so get someone
that close in one of the most secure
countries in the world yeah that is the
ultimate invasion my god if you can get
into wakanda yeah you deserve to
guarantee anywhere because that's that's
a hard place to get into like oh my
goodness yeah but she's also close to
the key players in the mcu now like
t'challa shuri bucky barnes like there's
a lot of you know really close people
that she can um
get get to and potentially
replace with a different squirrel like
replacing sherry as a squirrel would be
a huge guess like she's next in line for
the throne so it's like hey we got
sherry so now we can kill
her mom that would that would be tough
to be sure because they they'd expect
you to be really smart too you'd have to
be like very smart if you're gonna
replace shuri they'd be like hey sure we
need you to fix this nanotech and you're
just a scroll and you're like oh oh no i
don't know how to so this dude gonna say
the way that we view equilibrium in
stars is wrong because they found
conflicting evidence using the theory of
consiglio thesis that's like saying the
constraints of distortional drift
doesn't actually hinder the progression
of faulty and push field energy
converter well you know the squirrels
are pretty high-tech like they're pretty
they are like on a cosmic scale i feel
like they could probably keep up with
riwi but they might not have the exact
terminologies for like
earth stuff down but like
i feel like they're they're pretty damn
advanced okay um io makes more sense
than like okay i feel like they would
sniff out a coilier but like io could
kind of sneak through as a scroll i
think
uh and that would be really interesting
especially
if
maybe bucky barnes is a scroll mt maybe
io and bucky barnes are working together
it's like trolls
we know they got a little spark we got
they got a little spark there
what if they don't know that they're
each girl that's true maybe they don't
know that the other one's a skrull uh it
could be beautiful i mean crazy bucky is
a man who's been like put under on ice
many times right he's been frozen
in stasis and at any of those points you
could swap him out for like a scroll
right now he gets his arm blown off by
iron man and then they send him to
wakanda put him on ice again and i'm
sure they're doing medical checks and
they're going to say like oh it's a
human being don't worry but if our buddy
io is a skrull swaps out bucky barnes
flushes them down the toilet puts in a
scroll scroll bucky with missing an arm
and then they give this skrull bucky
like a mechanical arm oh baby look out
look out ryan look out yo
that would be so bananas
if like a squirrel replaced bucky and
like physically copied his metal arm and
then like somebody shot fake bucky in
the metal armor oh and the boys started
bleeding
it's like ah you got me
it could be dangerous could be that's
how everyone finds out that'll be
hilarious but no um bucky b like is a
really big uh scroll of candidate i feel
because like he's he's changed a lot too
he's changed a lot too yeah like he has
a new um life like the government sort
of forgave him yeah i guess for
everything that he's done yeah they
forgave the man you're free to go
get out of it
you're just free to go um that's kind of
sketchy like i feel like if bucky was a
scroll i feel like it makes sense for
him to get away with all those crimes
because like if other scrolls were in
the government they'd be like oh just
you can go um you know hail scroll drunk
wink wink
it also makes sense to swap him out in
wakanda because now he's like cured of
his brain stuff right you can say boxcar
to him all you want it doesn't do
anything but maybe that's because he's
not the same bucky anymore he just has
to pretend like uh oh is it gonna work
oh no it didn't work don't worry don't
worry i'm not a squirrel wink yeah what
that'd be crazy if they like they've
made like a squirrel sleeper agent
within bucky who doesn't remember that
he's a scroll oh
he has no idea he's great
oh my gosh like no idea because they
were just doing some mind stuff it's
like we need to we need you to go deep
undercover like this deep undercover uh
you need you to believe that you're
bucky bucky i feel like is a big
candidate because like he's just like
really close with like the new captain
america and like just
you know people have his trust now
because he's like this he's a relic of
the the world war two he's the only one
that they have left and like so now that
steve rogers is gone so i feel like it
just makes sense like hey people trust
this old white man trust this
world this world-renowned assassin who's
murdered many political leaders people
trust this guy what are we doing lock
bucky up what are we doing
yeah lucky lucky bucky needs to be
locked
or at least observed for a very long
time
who we got next buddy uh well let's
think about uh uh our good friend jimmy
wu okay a man of mystery and try to hand
magic okay he was assigned to work with
the fbi in san francisco but he suddenly
just like shows up in new jersey he's
he's chasing this person that we never
ever meet or never hear about ever again
and he gets involved in the west view
hex it's very
very suspicious okay and i think his
like high level of authority makes him a
good scroll candidate but i think and
now that we see that he's finally
mastered the magic arts right he can do
the sleight of hand it's because he's
the scroll he's not he's not real jimmy
wu can't do the magic okay
so i think jimmy jimmy's a low low
chance but it's a possibility it's a
possibility see i i would love if jimmy
who was a scroll because like i just
think that he has a really great funny
personality he would be a funny girl
he'll be a very goofy squirrel it's such
a funny squirrel and it would really
bump me out if jimmy was a skrull
because like he's i mean like again
scrolls can be good people there are
good scrolls and so like you know jimmy
the person could be a very good person
still but like man like he really fooled
me because like you really just
like he was one of the best parts of one
division am i
like it was just he's such a good
wholesome dude he's like man i would
have never suspected you so yeah i feel
like it makes sense considering that he
is in the fbi and he has all those
connections and he could easily um trick
everyone uh because he's just
the lead the last person on the fbi that
i would suspect to be a double agent the
last person um
but let's talk about tyler hayward
uh the very sketchy man very skeptical
from one division because uh speaking of
the west view hex tyler hayward makes
another great candidate as a skrull as
he is one of the higher ups at sword who
had a devious little plan of his own to
rebuild himself a vision robot man and
he does wind up getting arrested at the
end of one division but could he have
been a scroll this entire time i mean he
was pretty like nefarious he had some
stuff going on he was not very trusting
of other people he was trying to push
monaco away
he could be a scroll i think he could be
a scroll
especially if he was sensing that there
was something up with monica like he's
like oh this chick's got like late
latent powers and i said chick that's
that's tyler hayward that's not me
that's not me saying that's tyler
hayward
i'm not that misogynistic okay
that was tyler i'm speaking as
yeah there was something up with that
guy uh and he was like he really wanted
to kill monica really want to kill those
kids wanted to kill rwanda like he could
be a skrull now i don't think
i would think nick fury would be wise to
it because again i think nick fury's got
his plan of like let's look inside of
everybody's bodies to make sure they're
humans but he's up in space and if if
this guy worked his way into the
government as as a skrull version of
tyler hayward and got appointed to sword
nick fury might not have a say in it i
don't know i don't know he's he could be
one though yeah i feel like
having tyler hayward as um a squirrel
makes sense considering that sword is
supposed to be monitoring right like
aliens threats like especially in the
comics anyway like i know now it's like
the sentient weapon program yeah yeah
it's not like the sentient world
observation sentient weapon in terms of
the acronym for sword so um i feel like
having a scroll
in charge of like who watches
um what aliens go in and out of earth's
atmosphere
is perfect right like that you could
just be like yep um
those skrulls are coming to earth don't
even worry about it we're watching guys
they're
totally fine the border has been
patrolled
i mean so yeah no i feel like that does
make a lot of sense empty tyler
hayward's office is really sketchy to me
oh because like behind him he has this
like whole like constellation man right
and like i don't know he seems very
concerned with space even though like
that's what sword does like sword is all
about like satellites and whatever but
like he himself seems very obsessed with
space and so i feel like him being a
scroll and having his origins out in
space maybe like his office is decorated
in a sense of like hey i miss i miss
being out there in space and like i miss
my space space alien space space space
space state space i like i like the idea
that hayward just grow but nick fury
knew the whole time and he's just like
yeah i know he's a scroll he just got a
little insubordinate and went a little
crazy but yes he's a small yeah and
you're right mt they should have we saw
on the sword space station that there
were scrolls walking around like they're
working hand-in-hand and i think nick
fury well he'd won a few scrolls on the
ground
doing stuff but i think this scroll went
a little off book a little bit and he's
like man what are you doing well here's
someone that many have had suspicions on
for some time now and it's thaddeus
thunderbolt ross okay now with the
recent passing of the actor william hurt
who plays ross i don't know how likely
it would be that ross will now be
revealed to be a skrull but it could be
a way to suddenly explain his absence
now in the mcu if it's some sort of
thing where like oh they figured out he
was a skrull and they killed him i don't
know um you know thunderbolt ross was
obsessed obsessed with recreating the
super soldier serum something that the
skrulls would certainly have a lot of
interest in you know these are people
this is a race of aliens who've been
hunted down and almost annihilated
completely by the cree you know they
want to get their super scroll action
going on and if this is how we get to
super scrolls by them using the super
soldier serum like that would be very
interesting
um thunderbolt ross was in a position of
power high up in the military again had
a lot of insider knowledge of what was
going on so
him being a skrull does make a lot of
sense i think you know
the tragic death of william hurt really
kind of maybe changed a lot of their
plans who knows what they had going in
oh but if it's a way to like kind of
posthumously reveal that like he was a
skrull and he got eliminated either by
decree or something else i don't know
but i would love it if that daddy uh
thaddeus ross was a scroll and he was a
bad scroll
trying to get the super soldier serum
for the scrolls like that i think would
be a very interesting yeah i love that
idea a lot that'd be
so fun as a way to introduce the idea of
the super scroll because um we know that
the creed in in history were interested
in enhancing themselves right just be
more super but like you know with the
squirrels are a lot more super than
mccree like they can change their
physical appearance but we also know
that the super scroll is a thing in the
comics and that there is a next level to
the sprawl physiology that i feel like
would be prime for a sprawl uh ross to
sort of like shepherd it it's like hey
we're sort of trying to get this weird
like human science of creating super
soldier people and uh we almost got it
now for the glory of the scroll empire
but uh uh you know
this hulk guy is really uh getting in
our in our way
i think that
really annoying green person i i can't
relate uh instead of scroll
but yeah no it's i think that ross is a
really good really good chance but um
with the passing of william hurt it
would be it would be kind of like a
really yeah you'd have to really write
very well really really well yeah i
don't want to see a digital hurt walking
around i don't need that yeah i don't i
don't think they filmed anything for
secret invasion with william hurt i you
know as far as i know they didn't i
don't know but it would be very
interesting but yeah it's so sad because
i mean there was so much we wanted to
see from ross uh the character
in the mcu so
uh this this might be a fun way to like
send it off it's also i mean it's an
interesting way to think that like the
hulk's an accident that comes about
because the scrolls are messing around
trying to get the super soldier serum
and if if like bruce eventually found
out and was like wait i'm some mess up
by the scrolls and now you've got me an
abomination running around because the
skrulls wanted to get a super soldier
serum like that's wild that's wild stuff
i love that at least hey man that's
marvelous
um but let's talk about a different type
of uh a scroll candidate here a person
that had some type of interaction with
mr ross eliabalova um who debuted in
black widow elena belova first appeared
in the black widow film where natasha is
reunited with her long-lost sister from
another mister but was this her real
sister couldn't elena be a squirrel i
mean it's a perfect way to slip one in
right like here's someone you thought
was dead or gone or like you haven't
talked to in a long time and boom all
sudden she's back and here she is a
scroll let's grow
it makes she's like the easiest one to
kind of slip in i feel like because she
has this mysterious history oh yeah no
one's had tabs on her and all of a
sudden she's back i like this idea i
like i like her being a girl now we did
see her get blipped
we did see her get blipped but a skrull
can still be blipped
you know it could still happen it's true
that's just life you just gotta remember
when you come back to keep your form
that you were in when you went away
exactly i think that yelena beloveda is
the highest likely to be oh okay
because um she is uh just too too hot
and i think i don't trust that there's
no human i think that your face is too
attractive like yo there's like you
really messed up scroll because you made
a perfect human i don't understand i
don't i don't know how you can do that
i'm just being stupid that's it i think
oh no folks folks out there that's a
great pickup line if you're at a bar you
see someone you're attracted to you'd be
like yo
you have to get a x-ray of that body
because you must be a squirrel there's
no way there's no way a human could be
this guy you know because you out of
this world oh my god
it's possible
uh who else we got well speaking of
elena right we know she's working with
val or at least
was working for val we don't know if
she's still working with val but who is
this vowel really this is another
character who just kind of came out of
the shadows out of nowhere
wait a minute
who are you could val
be a scroll of her own putting together
a team of enhanced individuals who think
they're working with like a shadow arm
of the government but they're really
working for a shadow shadow arm of the
skrulls yes i think valve's a really a
major major candidate for school because
we know nothing about because we don't
really know what she's really up to
she's she is up to no good and it seems
that she doesn't want the avengers
around uh she put a hit on well this was
because of the whole hawkeye situation
where like she was more than happy to
put a hit on hawkeye um but i feel like
she she herself could secretly want all
the avengers gone so that she can um you
know help the secret invasion out yeah
cause like you just get rid of earth
defenses yeah yeah because uh those are
earth's biggest defenders right now
right and if you have a team that can
put down the avengers or the military or
whomever
boom very easy very easy this one might
be a little bit out there but like and
this would really make me sad but cassie
lane oh from the end oh
if you know how i feel why would you say
that could potentially be a scrawn
it would be a tragic tragic it would
hurt my soul because i love little
cassie like she's one of the cutest mcu
characters we ever had um if she was a
skrull
it would be sad but it would also make
sense considering that she is close to
scotland
close to hank pym who is famously
famously very private and so secluded
and keeps all of his research super
private so if he can find an in
to hank
through cassie lange
it just makes sense to me it'd be really
sad but like i could see the scroll the
squirrels making that play that does
make sense considering that scott has
not seen his daughter for a very long
time so like he doesn't really know
that cassie could be she did grow up
while he was gone and she was like i'm
cassie and he was like oh okay i guess
so sure uh just waiting outside very
suspiciously like oh here i am it's like
okay you're a brunette in cassie's house
so i guess i guess you're cassie
i've been an absentee dad for for five
years not my fault not my fault uh i was
in the quantum realm not my fault um i
was in a van for about five years just
thinking about my life now they did
change the actresses right for ant-man
quantum medium there's a new actress
cassie
we're not saying that's the difference
right we're saying at some point they
swapped it now maybe real cassie is
still alive let's let's hope if that's
the case maybe she's being kept
somewhere yeah as like a tool but i like
this idea mtu you had of like getting
close to hank pym because in the secret
or
yeah in the secret invasion in the
comics hank pym turned out to be a
scroll too there was a scroll wrote
playing hank pym and they could do that
here but i think they want to subvert
our expectations and not give us stuff
directly that they gave us in the comics
having cassie lang be the scroll would
be like a huge shocking reveal uh and it
would really really devastate uh hank
pan or scott lang it could cause like
all sorts of ramifications
i love this idea and i love the idea
that like uh scott has to then go find
his daughter wherever she's is being
held by the scrolls somewhere uh great
stuff yeah cause those girls of course
would want to get their hands on pimtec
how powerful that is of course they
would want to get to that it's super
like it's quantum energy and pymtek are
what the two
biggest
wants in the mcu and so like if hank pym
has access to both and like yeah it
would make sense for rhythm to go for
cassie as a uh as a scroll person but
you know obviously i guess scott or hope
would be even better but cassie's the
next best thing yeah so okay now let us
take our final picks here who are our
top two candidates for actually being
scrolls in the mcu hmm
okay i'll give you my two first mt
uh i laid out my argument before happy
hogan baby he's gonna turn out to be a
skrull
he's gonna be one of the good ones he's
going to be one of the good ones
but he's going to turn out to be a
scroll okay
uh i think i think you can pretty much
lock that one together i like that my
second pick
i kind of like one of the ones you
brought up and it really made me think i
think io my bf grow i think that's a
really good one
because you don't think about it right
away
and it's an important character that you
don't think about right away i love that
idea i think the skrulls would want to
get into wakanda you know big shit's
about to go down there uh having a
scroll there too i think is going to be
really important uh so those are my two
picks uh happy hogan and io what about
you mt i'm gonna go with
pepper potts oh
okay and i'm going to say pepper potts
is a squirrel because like after end
game i feel like pepper potts is a
character doesn't really have much to do
and like in order for her for her
character to have like you know
something fun to do that is like in
season in season variancy is the way to
go
i feel like that'd be a really fun
opportunity for morgan to sort of like
suss out the secret invasion for herself
she's she's the daughter of tony stark
and pepper potts so she's a very smart
cookie so for her to be like you're not
really acting like me you're not my mom
this is kind of weird yeah yeah i'm a
real mom i think that'd be really fun uh
but also i i really i love your idea
with io here i'm gonna have to also take
kyo because io she's uh she's two she's
one of the key members
and she is a good one
so like it would be like a very huge
like oh my god i can't believe this is
happening considering that she helped
heal bucky and like she's just so
trusted in what kind of society like i
would i would be shocked so like i
definitely suspect io for sure because
it's just it's a very smart move i think
aya was our big winner she's our big
winner and i know there's tons of other
candidates out there we didn't go
through every single one you know uh uh
everett ross is sitting out there
somewhere no one knows what he's up to
right uh uh you know there's people
everywhere there's definitely people in
the government who we haven't even met
yet uh are gonna be if you've got your
own picks like ant-man's crew
luis luisa's gotta be a scrum he's gotta
be he talks too fast he's gotta be a
stroke
tell us tell us how we tell a good human
story right yeah yeah tell us your
favorite ideas in the comments tell us
how wrong we are but man you guys are
gonna be eating crow when i o turns out
to be a crow but if you're not a scroll
be sure to head on over to new
rockstarsmerch.com to see all of our
awesome merch options right now our
partners at epic hero shop are rolling
out their epic kids line of merch that
has the perfect back to school item for
the nerdy kid in your life and don't
worry they still have all the awesome
merch options for nerdy adults as well
you so support the channel and grab
yourself and your little one some merch
over at new rockstarsmerch.com today but
before we continue we want to thank some
people that helped us bring big
questions to you people like mint mobile
because after years of fine print
contracts and getting ripped off by big
wireless providers if we've learned
anything it's that there is always a
catch like finding out your best friend
has actually been a scroll this entire
time it's a big old catch one of
marvel's biggest catches um but
thankfully mint mobile is out there
offering premium wildest service
starting at just 15 bucks a month and
the best part there's no catch
whatsoever mid mobile secret sauce is
that they're the first company to sell
wireless service online only they cut
off the cost of retail stores and pass
those sweet savings directly to you and
many folks here at new rockstars have
made the switch to mint mobile and the
quality of service that they get as well
as the savings that they get compared to
their old providers is quite amazing
it's quite drastic um and for anyone who
hates their phone bill mint mobile
offers premium wireless for just 15
bucks a month mid mobile gives you the
best rate whether you're buying for one
or a family and all plans come with
unlimited talk and text and high-speed
data delivered on the nation's largest
5g network so use your own phone with
any mint mobile plan and keep your same
phone number along with all of your
existing contacts switch to mit mobile
and get premium wireless service
starting at just 15 bucks a month to get
your new wireless plan for just 15 bucks
a month and get the plan shipped right
to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com big q that's mint
mobile.com
big q cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks
a month at mintmobile.com
big q hey you out there do you worry
about the many nefarious forces looking
to get a piece of your sweet sweet
computer well avast is a global leader
in cyber production for more than 30
years and trusted by over 435 million
users and they prevent over 1.5 billion
attacks every month a vast new
all-in-one solution avast one helps you
take control of your safety and privacy
online through a range of features a
vast one is their best protection yet
giving you everything you need to take
control of your safety and privacy
online and accessible through a single
super easy to use interface a vast
multitude of features provide you with
privacy and security as you scour the
web and even help with your machine's
performance making sure it's a ferrari
just
cruising down the highway of information
uh i myself i like their award-winning
anti-virus that stops viruses and
malware from harming my devices as well
as their data breach monitoring that
will alert me if my online accounts have
been compromised it happens too often
someone protect my online accounts uh
plus i always feel confident using
public wi-fi when i'm out there in the
wild thanks to their firewall protection
which keeps your personal information
secure and prevents others from trying
to access my computer and steal my data
i don't know how a firewall works but
avast does and they do a great job
protecting my stuff uh thanks to avas
for supporting big question you too can
confidently take control of your online
world with a vast one it helps you stay
safe from viruses phishing attacks
ransomware hacking attempts and other
cyber crimes learn more about vast one
at avast.com again that's a
a v a s t
dot com all right write it down it's
time for our bite size questions on your
own uh i need a fight source question
yeah it's so heavy
take a freaking bite take a bite
[Laughter]
all right brandon in black panther the
heart-shaped herb was able to grow due
to vibranium crashing into wakanda so
does this herb only grow in that
specific crash site or could it be
possibly found in other locations in
wakanda this is from uh trey suav1 on
twitter thank you trevor yes yes well
what we learned about the heart-shaped
herb's origin in the mcu occurs during
the opening narration of black panther
uh if you in case you forgot the
vibranium meteorite crashes in africa uh
in the area that is now wakanda and the
radiation from the vibranium quote
affected the plant life end quote around
the side of that crash okay
and it was bass who originally led
bashanga to the side of the heart-shaped
herb via a vision uh this is very
similar to how the heart-shaped herb
came to be in the comics it was also a
plant created via the radiation from the
vibranium meteorite that only grows in
wakanda so to get the heart-shaped herb
you need two things you need the
radiation from the pure vibranium along
with whatever the original plant was
that got mutated because unless this
meteorite had seeds on it it's taking a
plant that already exists and changing
it mutating it uh now we've been
speculating here on the channel that
there might be more vibranium out there
in the mcu because there is in the
comics there's other locations to find
vibranium so it's possible that there's
more heart-shaped herb and since
killmonger seemed to burn the entire
supply of heart-shaped herb we got to
hope there's a little bit more out there
somewhere
but what i'm wondering is if there's
other locations of vibranium there could
possibly be
different plants that have been mutated
that have different side effects so
maybe there's not like another
heart-shaped herb out there but there's
another plant that was mutated by
vibranium and has like different powers
now which could be very interesting if
there's all these mutated plants hanging
out there um so i bet there's more
heart-shaped herbs somewhere because
we're going to get another black panther
someone taking up the mantle yeah but i
i wonder if if they find more vibranium
out there in the world i i hope they
find some other mutated plants because i
think that would be very cool in captain
marvel um when the uh when the star
force was being ambushed by the
squirrels on torfa like torfa is a
planet that has vibranium in that
concept
vibranium stores there so um there's
potential for vibranium to be on that
planet for heart-shaped herbs to be on
that planet as well so hopefully we
learn more about torpor in the future um
in the mcu and hopefully torf has
vibranium in the mcu like they do in the
comics but now it's time for our box of
scraps right now
ready
my goodness
i'm opening up a box like a mine and
picking out a box of scraps and now i'm
making an iron man it's so cute out of
it cute i don't know what i'm saying
it's so adorable
but brandon if you could shape-shift it
to anyone anyone in the world and take
their place who would you choose
shape-shift into anyone and take their
place
oh man oh man
i don't want to be anyone famous that's
a lot of pressure
i guess if you could be like someone
who's just given money but you don't
have to do any work for it yeah yeah i
was shape-shifting to just like a
vanderbilt
someone in the vanderbilt family line
and just slip right in get my
inheritance say thank you very much and
walk out the door and that's it i don't
have to be famous that seems like
that'll work i don't want to have like a
a powerful job that's a lot of work i
just want to shape-shift into someone
who can come and collect the family's
trust uh and then walk back out the door
again i respect that the easy peasy
that's what i'm looking for
nothing too crazy that's a life very
simple very smart stuff uh that's my
choice very what about umt you know what
i want to go
down to somewhat similar route but you
know you know me in my uh my weird
obsessions okay i'm going to wish to be
haley steinfeld's dog
empty the life the greatest life of all
time getting walked by hailey steinfeld
eater
[Laughter]
no okay no you can do it you can do it
we know the squirrels can be animals you
can be an animal if you want
it's true
i would i would totally would not mind
being having seinfeld's dog
when hayley steinfeld gets married
to a human being empty and you have to
be at the wedding and your little dog
bow tie with the rings tied to your back
you're gonna resent it that day you're
going to resent it that day all right
also at some point haley's going to be
like i'm being on the ground haley's
going to be like why is my dog 50 years
old why don't this dog die
somebody said deliberately
[Laughter]
did my dog just try to kill my husband
what's happening i was fit
my dog won't stop growling at my husband
google search but that is it for this
episode of big question i want to thank
brandon for joining me on this episode
as always please follow brandon at
grindenberric on twitter he's an amazing
man you can follow me at mastertainment
on twitter if you want to see me tweet
some weird [ __ ] but most importantly you
can follow new rockstars everywhere we
are on the internet and when you do on
youtube make sure you hit that
notification bell so you can get
notifications every time we upload a
video and if you want to continue the
new rockstars conversation join the new
rockstars discord server if you're over
18 and interested just click the link
for the new rockstars discord in the
description box below and join the
conversation today we love you guys so
much and thank you guys for spending
time with us we'll see you guys next
time goodbye
[Music]
you